[Musique]
la reine qui si j'y fus un diable est un
ange tout plein de blâme et pleines de
louanges et soutint l'état et l'état
misent à barres elle filme un accord est
pas moins de débats et l'enfant à trois
rois et cinq guerres civiles fit bâtir
des châteaux et ruiné des villes fille
bien de bonnes lois et de mauvais édits
souhaite lui passe en enfer et paradis
ces quelques vers glanées par le
mémorialiste pierre de l'étoile après la
mort de catherine de médicis dépeignent
une reine la personnalité double si la
reine noire décrite par alexandre dumas
dans la reine margot lui confère une
image emblématique de souveraine
sanguinaire l'histoire révèle pourtant
un personnage brillant est autrement
plus complexe mais c'est elle celle que
l'on appelait la florentine ouh ouh là
là conspiratrice parce qu'elle passe sa
vie à conspirer c'est elle qui va
assurer le gouvernement pendant des
années catherine de médicis héritière
florentine effacé derrière son époux le
roi henry 2 mais toujours conscient de
son rôle au sommet de l'état se révèle
être une fine politique sous le règne de
ses fils françois deux chars le neuf et
orrit toi catherine de médicis a un sens
de la famille très fort elle sera pour
ces différents fils une mère attentive
parfois un petit peu envahissante mais
très très attachées à l'exercice de
leurs autorités soucieuses de maintenir
l'intégrité d'un royaume déchiré par les
guerres de religion elle tente d'abord
de mener une politique de conciliation
en affirmant une volonté royale
par delà les clivages des partis et des
confessions
face à l'échec de cette politique elle
se pose à l'heure en souveraine
implacable elle entreprend une
répression qui va conduire au tristement
célèbre massacre de la saint barthélemy
catherine de médicis c'est un le 5
janvier 15 189 100 assisté à la mort de
son fils préféré henri iii qui entraîne
avec lui la chute irrémédiable de la
dynastie des valois
après deux cent soixante ans de règne
[Musique]
la dynastie des valois accède au trône
de france entre s128 après la mort sans
héritier légitime du dernier rois
capétiens direct charles iv c'est alors
son cousin philippe de valois qui
devient roi sous le nom de philippe 6 il
ouvre la voie en valois le plus célèbre
de l'histoire
françois 1er
certains historiens partagent les deux
cent soixante ans du règne des valois
selon trois phases la survie de 13 cents
37 à 14 153 les réalisations de 14 153 à
15 159 et la catastrophe de 15 159 à 15
189 la période de la survie fait
référence la guerre de cent ans qui se
déclenche quand un autre cousin edouard
iii d'angleterre se pose en prétendant
au trône de france et remettent en
question la légitimité des valois après
avoir bouter les anglais hors du royaume
les rois valois hf de rassembler les
provinces et installe une autorité
royale incontestable ils s'opposaient
alors au puissant ducs de bourgogne qui
rêvent de porter la couronne
ces derniers s'empresse donc de conclure
des mariages d'alliances avec les
habsbourgs dynastie rival qui règne sur
l'espagne l'autriche et de saint-empire
romain germanique
ces liens instaure alors un véritable
climat d'hostilité entre valois et
habsburg
territoire des habsbourg encerclent le
royaume de france et françois 1er entend
bien leur démontrer sa force
[Musique]
poursuivant le rêve italien de ses
prédécesseurs charles 8 et louis xii
temps de faire valoir ses droits sur
l'italie du nord se devait elle naît à
la fin du xvème siècle à partir du
moment où la france commence à prendre
une autorité en europe après la guerre
de cent ans après s'être construit à
l'intérieur du royaume et elle où elle
commence justement à développer l'idée
de d'une idée dans pire qu'elle pourrait
construire à partir de la péninsule
italienne
et ce duel va donc commencer à partir de
maximilien à l'époque de maximilien et
cher le 8 et louis xii et il va devenir
beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup plus
violents à partir de 15 cents dix neuf à
partir du moment où françois 1er va
envisager l'élection impérial et donc
prétendre officiellement à la couronne
du saint-empire
à la brillante victoire de marignan 15
115 succès de l'élection de charles
quint comme empereur des rom à 15 cents
dix-neuf le désastre de pavie en 15 126
consacre alors la suprématie espagnole
françois 1er est fait prisonnier et en
gage de respect de l'humiliant traité de
cambrai qui l'obligent à abandonner ses
prétentions italienne le roi doit se
résoudre à laisser ses deux fils
françois et henry comme otage dans les
geôles espagnoles pendant plusieurs
années
[Musique]
l'idée pour françois 1er en tout cas
dans les années 15 130 parce qu'il n'a
plus d'argent pour faire monter une
armée
eh bien il va essayer de jouer avec la
diplomatie et comme charles quint va
mettre un holà à ces fermes par rapport
au projet du mariage de son fils de son
fils henry avec une de ses filles à
venir ou une de ses nièces et bien
françois 1er va chercher d'autres alliés
en italie parce qu'il y en a plus du
tout et il va sur ses deux pattes c'est
le plus de pole le plus la lazio qui
pourrait être le plus puissant pas
forcément médicaments mills au plan
politique et clémence et allèrent à
l'époque la nièce catherine qui a
exactement le même âge à 15 jours près
que landry et qui vit dans un couvent
qui potentiellement héritière de
de florence mais aussi du duché d'urbain
et que ce mariage là pour françois 1er
permettait donc du coup d'implanter la
france dans un territoire où la france
devait de pouvait avoir des droits donc
sur le duché d'urbain et avec l'appui en
plus politique de du pape qui lui
permettait ce soit de revenir sur milan
soit d'aller vers naples
françois 1er négocié avec le pape
clément 7 alors en guerre contre les
habsbourg un mariage d'intérêt entre son
fils cadet henri est l'héritière
orpheline des médicis catherine issu
d'une puissante lignées patriciennes
italienne la jeune femme n'est pas de
son royal peu importe car en tant que
cadet henri n'est pas destiné à régner
sauf en cas de décès de son frère aîné
ce qui va se produire en 15 136 les uns
florence petite fille du célèbre laurent
le magnifique grand mécène et diplomates
fille de laurent de médicis duc d'urbino
et de bas de laine de la tour d'auvergne
l'adulte gecina est l'héritière d'une
immense fortune
devenue orpheline dans sa première année
catherine est élevé à la cour des papes
médicis durant la guerre sanglante qui
les chassent de florence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'union de catherine et henry est
célébrée à marseille le 28 octobre 15
133 ce mariage politique s'accompagne
d'un traité d'alliance entre la france
et la papauté qui promet une aide pour
la reconquête de milan ainsi qu'une dose
substantielle
[Musique]
mais la mort du pape l'année suivante
anéanti les projets de françois 1er
le nouveau souverain pontife s'allie à
l'empereur le mariage médicis valois
n'est plus d'aucune utilité pour la
france
alors henri épouse catherine de médicis
à laquelle il finira par faire des
enfants au bout d'une dizaine d'années
alors qu'il vivait tendrement avec diane
de poitiers avec son institutrice qui un
jour à une déclaration d'henri qui lui a
dit je vous aime
alors c'est assez c'est assez étonnant
parce que diane de poitiers qui était la
plus belle femme du royaume dit on avait
elle a 15 ans épouse est un vieux barbon
de 55 ans le sénéchal de grancey le
château de brézé le sait le châle de
normandie après sa mort elle va
succomber aux avances d'henri deux
parentes de catherine par sa mère diane
de poitiers devient sa dame de compagnie
âgé de 30 ans la jeune veuve à la beauté
antique et au caractère affirmé va
devenir sa grande rivale
[Musique]
catherine de médicis elle sait
parfaitement que les mariages sont des
mariages politiques sont pas forcément
des mariages d'amour ne mène jamais
pratiquement et que l'idée d'une
favorite ou d'une concubine existe déjà
la cour de florence il n'avait plein
cours de rome il avait plein aussi en
italie c'était monnaie courante et elle
est arrivée en france et elle a vu son
époux avec une maîtresse sap a dû
choquer grand monde en tout cas et
surtout pas elle
catherine supporte avec humilité
l'omniprésence insultante que sa rivale
diane est sûre d'elle et jouit d'une
grande influence à la cour
pour légitimer sa place catherine sait
qu'elle doit donner un héritier à henry
mais elle va rester stérile durant les
dix premières années de leur mariage
brillante et cultivé l'héritière d'une
famille de mécènes aimant le luxe et les
fêtes
catherine use de tous les stratagèmes
pour gagner l'affection de son beau père
le roi françois 1er
elle se tourne aussi vers les sciences
occultes afin de trouver un remède à
cette infertilité qui fragilise son
statut
catherine donne finalement naissance à
un premier fils futur françois 215 144
puis suivront dix autres enfants dont 7
survivront jusqu'à l'âge adulte
[Musique]
après la mort de françois promis en 15
147 henry 2 accède au trône et la
florentine est propulsée reine de france
le roi poursuit le rêve italien de ses
prédécesseurs qui se transforme en duel
valois habsburg en 15 155 l'empereur
charles quint abdique en faveur de son
fils philippe ii d'espagne l'année
suivante
marie tudor reine d'angleterre et
d'irlande et nouvelle épouse de philippe
deux déclare la guerre à henri ii les
forces espagnoles envahissent la france
depuis les pays-bas et remporte une
victoire écrasante à 50 à catherine de
médicis assure la régence et manoeuvre
habilement avec le parlement pour
obtenir les fonds nécessaires à la
poursuite de la guerre
catherine de médicis pendant tout le
règne de henri donné qu'une reine de
france qui fait des enfants elle a eu
deux fois la possibilité de régence lors
des deux voyages que henry 2 va faire en
allemagne mais durent que quelques
semaines et son pouvoir législatif
politique les nuls une reine de france
n'a pas de pouvoir tant que son mari et
vivant et existe
la paix de cateau cambrésis signé les 2
et 3 avril 15 159 met un terme aux
guerres d'italie et confirme la
suprématie espagnole en europe
en quoi consistent ces accords et bien
se sont sensiblement des affaires
religieuses parce que henry 2 cède
toutes les ses prétentions sur l'italie
en demandant à l'espagne de l'aider et
éventuellement contre les huguenots et
avec l'angleterre
eh bien il joue le jeu contraire il dit
à elisabeth la reine d'angleterre
eh bien écoutez en effet vous avez
consacré le culte anglicans chez vous je
ferme les yeux mais vous me rendais
calais il a récupéré chaldée cette pub
du 459 est essentiel parce que elle va
permettre à la fois de mettre un point
final à plus de 40 ans de guerre ce
n'est pas rien à recréer des liens entre
l' empire conduit non plus par charles
quint parce qu'il a abdiqué mais par son
fils philippe 2 et en partie en tout cas
et par l'angleterre qui maintenant est
sous la tutelle de elisabeth 1ère c'est
aussi une période donc où on affirme où
la france va affirmer son abandon de
l'italie justement cette paix est bien
aura l'avantagé au moins d'avoir repris
calais et donc empêcher les anglais de
débarquer sur la france aussi facilement
et puis aussi de garder ces trois
évêchés toulouse verdun et metz qui
étaient des territoires qui étaient des
enclaves à la main à l'intérieur du
royaume de france et qui en tout cas
proche du les proches du duché de
lorraine et qui permettait aux allemands
ou en tout cas où le rose en périodes de
venir plus rapidement en france et est
ravagé la picardie la champagne voire
même menacé paris stratégiquement
s'était finalement très très faim
[Applaudissements]
la réforme protestante séduit de plus en
plus d'adeptes et henry 2 ne parvient
pas à instaurer l'unité religieuse du
royaume
il mène alors une politique répressive à
l'égard des huguenots la période nouri 2
c'est le début des guerres de religion
exactement et henri ii n'est pas très
partisan de la cause hugues moutouh
protestante
en cela il est extrêmement influencé par
diane de poitiers qui a été élevé dans
le catholicisme pur et dur et qu'il lui
dit henry a lui dit il ne faut pas que
le lait nous est une influence
considérable
on va d'ailleurs à cause des loups ou
grâce à elle dirait disaient les
catholiques de cette époque-là signe les
10 des coûts ans qui interdisait le
culte protestant sur le royaume de
france
[Musique]
pour concrétiser la paix avec les
habsbourg
des festivités sont organisées et
célèbre des mariages princiers
elisabeth de valois est une des filles
de henri ii et va épouser donc après
comme tous les pères se finissent
souvent par des mariages
elle va épouser philippe ii d'espagne
est donc lié par le mariage
en plus des traités de paix et d toutes
les contrats qui ont été faites donc lié
spirituellement deux nations qui se sont
fait la guerre pendant 40 ans c'est à
dire la france est l'empiré henri ii est
un colosse bel homme rompu à tous les
exercices physiques il tient beaucoup de
françois 1er son père et henry 2 ème
beaucoup l'un des grands sports des
genres de sa catégorie j'allais dire
c'est à dire des rois des princes de la
grande noblesse qu'elle est tournoi se
substitue delà de la guerre lors d'un
tournoi henri ii affronte le capitaine
de sa garde écossaise le duc de
montgomery la lance de ce dernier se
brise atteignant le home du roi et lui
et courchevel
victime d'une infection le souverain
c'est un après dix jours d'agonie
le 10 juillet 15 159 la mort de henry 2
qui a été une mort alors complète pas
inattendu était là dans la force de
l'âge et sa disparition va évidemment
créer des troubles très profond une
instabilité très profond de toute façon
tous très gens c'est une catastrophe
dans le système royal français et cette
mort va apparaître comme un signe pour
les contemporains du désaveu de dieu à
l'égard de ce qui se passe en france
avec catherine de médicis il a tout de
même quatre fils capable de régner il a
le petit françois il à charles il à
henry est il encore un petit dernier qui
est recul le duc d'alençon
donc il se serait bien le diable quand
même que parmi ces quatre héritiers il
n'y en ait pas un qui est un fils
susceptibles de régner un jour ou
l'autre
après avoir passé 26 ans dans l'ombre
l'épousé d'henri 2 l'italienne catherine
de médicis endosse alors un rôle public
auprès de leurs trois fils elle va se
consacrer à poursuivre l'oeuvre de son
défunt mari
[Musique]
princesse de la renaissance et digne
héritière des médicis ces grands mécènes
de florence catherine entend bien
imposer sa marque en important les modes
et les moeurs italienne à la cour elle
souhaite aussi poursuivre l'oeuvre
architecturale de françois 1er et
d'henri 2
pour cela il lui faut effacer l'amour
gravés dans la pierre des châteaux
royaux de son mari pour sa rivale
diane de poitiers cette dernière doit
échanger chenonceau contre chaumont et
restituer comme celle usage à la mort du
souverain
les bijoux de la couronne
diane se retire ensuite dans son château
d'anet et catherine entreprend la
transformation des monogrammes de sa
rivale qui ornent les résidences royales
[Musique]
catherine de médicis est une bâtisseuse
comme françois 1er l'a été et elle est
dans la même logique c'est à dire
qu'elle construit beaucoup elle a des
tas de projets tout le temps mais finit
pas grand chose alors soit parce que là
d'autres idées soit parce qu'ils
manquent d'argent soit parce que la cour
a changé pour des raisons politiques
vont à changer de lieu
cc construction personnelle n'est en fin
de compte elle pourrait se résumer à 3
agrandissements de chenonceau le palais
des tuileries qu'elle va se construire
au milieu des jardins du louvre et qui
met ce qui ne sera pas achevée non plus
et puis peut-être ce mausolée dont on
oublie souvent l'existence qu'elle avait
voulu construire à l'abbaye de saint
denis juste à côté de l'abbaye pour
faire une sorte de lieu à la gloire de
son mari d'elle et de ses enfants
l'hôtel des tournelles qui a vu mourir
henry 2 est complètement abandonné
catherine de médicis décide de
construire à cet emplacement sa nouvelle
résidence parisienne et de tracer des
jardins sur les vestiges d'anciennes
fabrique de tuiles ce sera le jardin des
tuileries
le palais des tuileries que la reine
mère fera sortir entièrement de terre
est le plus vaste projet de construction
du dernier quart du 16e siècle
l'architecte à l'origine de l'oeuvre
philibert delorme enseigne à la france
le style classique rationnelle et
régulier pour plaire à la reine
il y ajoute des ornementations et de
riche matériau les colonnes pilastres et
lucarne des tuileries sont des
chefs-d'oeuvre de la sculpture de cette
époque
seul le rez-de-chaussée de la petite
galerie est achevé de son vivant ce qui
permettra plus tard à henri iv d'ajouter
un second étage pour relier les deux
palais du louvre et des tuileries à la
mort de l'homme en 15/100 70 jean
bullant lui succède à la charge
d'architecte en chef auprès de catherine
de médicis
elle lui commandent la construction d'un
tout nouveau palais l'autel de la reine
qu'on appellera plus tard l'hôtel de
soissons
il n'en reste aujourd'hui qu'une simple
colonnes doriques la colonne de
l'horoscope
[Musique]
catherine de médicis après la mort
d'henri 2 1
un grand projet évidemment c'est de
faire construire à saint denis là où
tous les rois de france depuis depuis
l'origine était enterré à la basilique
de saint denis une merveilleuse chapelle
qui s'appellera la chapelle des valois
et puis elle va aussi continuer de faire
quelques d'améliorer quelques châteaux
elle continue l'oeuvre architecturale
qui avaient souhaité son mari henri ii
[Musique]
la mort accidentelle d'henri 2 est une
catastrophe pour le royaume
la stabilité qu'il incarnait laisse
place à une lutte sans merci pour la
région avec son cortège d intrigues ces
troubles internes vont plonger la france
dans les sanglantes guerres de religion
rongé par une haine fratricide le
royaume va se déchirer
pendant près de 40 ans elle va devenir
la meilleure du prochain roi françois 2
mais qui est officiellement majeur est
capable de renier parce qu'il a plus de
15 ans la majorité des rois est à 14
même si jusqu à 20 ans il a besoin d'un
tuteur et c'est là dessus qu'on va jouer
c'est là-dessus qu'elle va jouer avec le
parti de guise
c'est à dire en gros mon fils est roi de
france fait toutes les lois en son nom
mais je serai à côté
le jeune roi françois 2 n'a que 15 ans
il est majeur mais manipulable et les
familles nobles rival voit donc
l'opportunité d'accroître leur pouvoir
au sommet de l'état la maison de bourbon
compte un premier prince du sang le roi
de navarre
antoine de bourbon ainsi que ses deux
frères le cardinal charles de bourbon le
prince louis ii comté antoine de bourbon
et louis de condé sont des adeptes de la
religion protestante
face à eux très catholique guise issus
de la maison de lorraine sont
représentés par le duc françois de guise
[Musique]
s'ils ne peuvent revendiquer aucune
lignée royale
il compte pourtant dans leurs rangs une
reine decosse leur soeur mary 2 ghz
ayant épousé jacques 5 décosse est une
reine de france marc histoire l'épousé
de françois 2
[Musique]
manipulé par l'église
françois deneux va régner qu'une année
la reine mère catherine de médicis est
écarté des affaires du royaume alors
qu'une terrible répression religieuse
commence à l'encontre des protestants en
mars qu'un 160 les gentilhommes
protestants fomentait une conspiration
visant à soustraire le roi de la tutelle
déguise c'est la conjuration d'amboise
le coup d'état est chaud et les conjurés
sont exécutés mais de nouveaux troubles
éclatent permettant à catherine de
médicis d'affermir son rôle politique
afin de stabiliser l'état elle s'appuie
sur son conseiller le chancelier michel
de l'hospital réputé modéré et humaniste
influencé par les idées d'erasme il est
défavorable à une division religieuse
qui affaiblirait le royaume il réprouve
cependant l'usagé de la force contre les
protestants les 10 de romorantin en mai
15 cent soixante marques pour un temps
la fin des persécutions d'acord aux
protestants la liberté de conscience
tout en leur refusant la liberté de
culte
une tolérance tacite s'installe en
attendant la réunion des états généraux
prévus pour décembre 15 160 une fois ce
complot achevé l'église paresse ou tout
puissant ils peuvent même envisagé un
temps de faire exécuter le prince de
condé ce qui n'arrivera pas mais les
cartes vont être très très vite rabattu
car cette situation qui est celle de
l'automne 459 est complètement remodelé
à la mort de françois 2 dans l'hiver 15
159 460 qui voit effectivement la
disgrâce sensible déguise et le retour
au pouvoir
autour du petit roi charles neuf qui la
lui est mineur effectivement il a passé
13 ans révolus dont il est il est en
situation de minorité d'un groupe
constitué de la reine mère katherine de
nouveaux personnages qu'on était des
personnages importants sous le règne de
théories de le maréchal de s'entendre et
le connétable de montmorency et antoine
de bourbon
le prince roi de navarre roi d'une
partie de la navarre et qui est un
prince de la famille royale la princesse
du sang c'est autour de ces gens là que
le pouvoir de nouveau s'articuler et
donc l'église ont une position
exceptionnelle à ce moment là cette
position va changer avec la mort de
françois deux parce que je pense que
c'est à la mort de françois 2 que
veuve de henri 2 catherine de médicis si
je peux dire se réveille
[Musique]
le 5 décembre 15 160 francs soit deux
jeunes rois à la santé fragile succombe
[Musique]
charles second fils d'henri ii et de
catherine de médicis devient roi à 10
ans sous le nom de charles neuf mais il
est trop jeune pour conduire le
gouvernement du royaume et une lutte
féroce s'engage pour la régence antoine
de bourbon affronte catherine de médicis
pour faire valoir son droit légitime
mais il n'est pas de taille face à cette
redoutable négociatrice il renonce
contre la charge de lieutenant général
du royaume et la reine mère devient
officiellement régente la région se
montre favorable au dialogue religieux
lors du colloque de poissy du 9
septembre au 14 octobre 15 161 catherine
de médicis envisage une réconciliation
religieuses nationales mais sept
confrontations théologiques entre les
protestants représenté par le
réformateur théodore de bèze et les
ambassadeurs catholique de la cour est
un échec
la régente projet alors de mettre en
place une tolérance civile provisoire
pour préserver la paix ou éponger
l'énorme dette de l'état et l'obtient
également l'aide financière de l'église
de france menacée d'être dépossédé de
ses biens
[Musique]
elle va commencer un jeu de bascule un
jeu qui va consister à essayer
d'équilibrer le rôle d'église en
s'alliant chaque fois que l'occasion se
présente avec des chefs du parti
protestant la région poursuit l'effort
de tolérance en promulguant lady de
janvier 15 162 légalise le culte public
des réformes et à condition qu'ils
s'exercent deux jours sans armes et à
l'extérieur des villes les protestants
doivent garder les limites de leur culte
est en réalité l'église catholique ne
veut pas de ces élites de tolérance et
c'est là où elles poussent les grands
seigneurs que song is montmorency
saint-andré à faire véritablement la
guerre aux protestants ce triumvirat
jura l'heure de défendre la religion
catholique contre l'hérésie
bien que protestants antoine de bourbon
choisi le camp des catholiques et
renforce ainsi l' influence du duc de
guise
françois de guise et des d'autres
seigneur veut empêcher de se tenir à
vassy un grand qu'une ville close un
grand rassemblement de huguenots et à ce
moment-là il envoie des soldats pour
l'empêcher mais bien une rébellion début
nos qui veulent pratiquer leur culte et
s'ensuit un véritable massacre
et à partir de ce massacre de vassy
commence la guerre civile
ghz et montmorency contraignent la
régente et le roi charles ii 9 alors à
fontainebleau a regagné la capitale
le prince de condé exhorte les
protestants à prendre les armes pour
libérer le roi qu'il estime prisonniers
d'élise le 2 avril 15 162 il s'empare
d'orléans puis le tour sonne le début de
la première guerre de religion mais la
régente se range du côté des catholiques
cette première guerre fois disparaître
deux personnages essentiels
antoine de bourbon dont le fils henri de
navarre devient premier prince du sang
le fervent catholique duc françois de
guise
lady d'amboise signé le 19 mars 15 163
met un terme aux hostilités et marque le
retour de la tolérance civile depuis
l'avènement de charles neuf et catherine
de médicis est un élément extrêmement
important ça veut pas dire que charles
neuf n'existe pas mais c'est un roi qui
échangent facilement de davie il est
très influençable et il est
particulièrement influençable par sa
mère par catherine de médicis délivrées
de la tutelle du duc de guise
catherine de médicis fait proclamer la
majorité de chars le neuf le 17 août 15
163,6 la régence s'achève officiellement
dans les faits la reine-mère conserve
toute son influence
l'année suivante elle entreprend avec le
roi un grand tour de france afin de le
présenter à ses sujets et de lui faire
connaître son royaume
poser un parti protestant à la monarchie
massivement soutenu par les catholiques
ça c'est le cas de figure qui va durer
pendant disons les dix bonnes premières
années
après l'échec de la surprise de mots
tentative du prince de condé pour
s'emparer du roi charles 9 ans 15 cent
soixante sept duels religion entre
catholiques et protestants en flammes de
nouveau le royaume mais la disgrâce du
chancelier modéré michel de l'hospital
en septembre 15 168 met fin à la
politique de tolérance alors catherine
de médicis bien elle a cherché
constamment la conciliation
elle a essayé d'éviter les guerres de
religion elle a essayé de faire des
éditos les anciens a eu plusieurs
mais ça n'a pas marché elle a eu cette
idée funeste lors voyant que les édits
ne fonctionnait pas de passer à la
répression féroce dans les années 15
cent soixante dix une nouvelle
génération entre dans le conflit
le nouveau duc de guise le catholique
henry poursuit la cause de son père et
le fils d'antoine de bourbon henri de
bourbon
le jeune prince de navarre assume
courageusement le rôle de chef des
protestants après la mort de son oncle
le prince de condé la paix de saint
germain est signée le 8 août 15 170 et
le royaume jouit d'une paix temporaire
charles neuf épouse elisabeth d'autriche
mais charles et de caractère instable et
en grandissant il s'est mis à haïr sa
mère et à jalouser sa relation avec son
fils préféré le futur henri iii
catherine a encore suffisamment
d'ascendant sur charles neuf jusqu'au
moment où il rencontre une figure
paternelle
le héros de la réforme l'amiral gaspard
de coligny
sous son influence charles neuf incline
du côté des protestants résiste à
l'emprise de sa mère et se méfient
déguisent
charles neuf incline à une véritable
alliance militaire avec les protestants
le chef militaire des protestants et
temps l'amiral de coligny le chef
on peut dire du point de vue du prestige
du point de vue de la relation avec la
famille royale c'est henri de navarre
mais le chef militaire c'est l'amiral de
coligny catherine de médicis depuis
l'avènement de charles 9 jouent ce jeu
de bascule entre l'église et le parti
protestant lorsqu elles inclinent du
côté du parti protestant
elle met tout son poids dans la balance
pour conclure un mariage très politique
entre l'un des princes du parti
protestant qui s'appelle henri de
navarre le futur henri iv et l'une de
ses filles marguerite elle qu'on
appellera plus tard la reine margot
alors le mariage d'henri de navarre et
de la petite margaux la future reine
margot la fille de catherine de médicis
est prévue donc on a prévu de le
célébrer à paris a priori ça s'annonce
bien puisque tous les luxes nos sont
venus accompagner leur chef le jeune
henry et on se prépare de grandes
réjouissances mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que catherine de médicis l'on
surnomme là serpente dans l'histoire
catherine de médicis à une arrière
pensée une arrière pensée dans le crâne
elle envisage manifestement de venir à
bout les protestants
[Musique]
les ghz favorise donc favorise par house
et le climat qui en est la cause
mais un attentat contre colis et qui ne
permet pas de tuer collini mais lui
arrache un doigt le blesse à l'épaule et
c'est alors et coligny et les
protestants crient vengeance vengeance
et catherine de médicis ne sait plus
trop quel camp choisir
charles neuf lui est indigné par
l'attend pas et va visiter coligny dans
sa maison lui dit justice sera faite et
c'est catherine de médicis se dit oui
mais nous sommes à paris
à paris ce sont les forces ultra
catholique qui l'emportent cd ghz
c'est pas très bon ce qui est en train
de se passer en ce moment puis je
voudrais pas non plus que cole inique
est un personnage raid s'empare de la
direction des affaires par l'influencé
qu'il exerce auprès de charles neuf et
donc dans la nuit suivante
elle s'allie au guide pour expliquer à
charles neuf que les protestants ont
décidé d'attenter à sa vie de s'emparer
de lui mais dit un complot ils sont des
milliers à paris c'est pas étonnant
parce que beaucoup de nobles protestants
ou de soldats protestants sont venus de
province à l'occasion des cérémonies du
mariage de henri de navarre et donc
c'est ainsi qu'est décidé le massacre de
la saint barthélemy la peur et la colère
déclenché si charles neuf une crise de
folie
il aurait alors déclaré tu es l'amiral
mais tuez les tous pour qu'il n'en reste
pas un pour me le reprocher
on ferme les portes de paris les cloches
du beffroi de l'église saint germain
l'auxerrois sonne le signal du massacre
de la saint barthélémy dans la nuit du
23 au 24 août 15 172 l'enfer se déchaîne
[Musique]
les gardes suisses postés à l'extérieur
de la chambre de coligny sont facilement
abattu l'amiral et poignardé et
précipité par la fenêtre il tombe au
pied du duc de guise qui l'attend pour
l'achever
[Musique]
alors qu'elle ne devait frapper que les
chefs la folie meurtrière incontrôlable
c'est en bientôt à tous les protestants
de paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout a dérapé et il ya une sorte de
folie insurrectionnel révolutionnaire
dirons-nous qui a consisté dans les rues
de paris a tué tous protestants au
louvre a tué tous protestant à dans la
seine ont jeté des corps et puis après
ouais qui se noyait pas assez vite pour
les retirer avec une pique ou une lan
sont les poignarder on les remettait
danse est une espèce de folie criminelle
je
la cour d'espagne et la cour de rome les
deux grandes tours catholiques celles
qui pèsent le plus lourd sans doute à ce
moment là le pape d'un côté et le roi
d'espagne l'on se réjouisse absolument
de cette opération dont il faut bien
voir qu'elle est conçue par eux et en
partie parce qu'ils l'ont mise en oeuvre
comme une purification du royaume de
france n'a royaume qui est pollué par
une souillure religieuse fondamentale et
on ne peut pas s'attendre à leurs yeux
quoi que nous en pensions aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas s'attendre à leurs yeux à ce
que la la la colère de dieu se retire du
royaume de france
tant que cette pollution et j'emploie le
mot à dessein il est employé à l'époque
un temps que cette pollution ne sera pas
nettoyé
[Musique]
après ce terrible massacre la santé de
charlot 9 décline hanté par le souvenir
des protestants assassiné il confie ses
remords à sa nourrice qui reste à son
chevet usés physiquement et moralement
il n'a plus la volonté de vivre
il est emporté à 24 ans par la
tuberculose le 30 mai 15 174
[Musique]
catherine de médicis endeuillées et de
nouveau en charge du pouvoir
elle envoie un message et en pologne
cherchez le fils suive un henry qui doit
porter à son tour la couronne de france
[Musique]
à la mort de charles neuf catherine de
médicis n'a qu'une hâte c'est d'envoyer
des émissaires en pologne pour dire à
son petit chéri à henry ça y est le
trône est libre il faut que tu viennes
le récupérer henry avait à peine de
commencer de gouverner fort mal
d'ailleurs parce que la pologne ne
l'intéressait pas il quitte la pologne
avec ses amis qui d'ailleurs confisqué
tout l'argent qui a dans les caisses de
la pologne
ils descendent vers vers venise où il va
rester pendant six mois avant de venir
hérité le trône de france alors que le
royaume de france est plongée dans une
cinquième guerres de religion henri iii
est couronné à reims 13 février 15 175
il doit alors faire face à une situation
inédite les catholiques modérés réunis
derrière son frère le dernier fils de
catherine de médicis françois d'alençon
combat désormais aux côté des
protestants contre les troupes royales
la situation va se compliquer par
l'apparition d'un parti catholique
favorable à des réformes politiques et
qui peut dans certains cas s'allier avec
des protestants contre la monarchie
ce qu'on appelle les mâles comptant dans
les années qu'un cent soixante dix pour
porter un programme de réformes c'est
pas des anti monarchistes du tout et ils
sont pas protestants ils sont bien
catholique mais ils sont prêts dans
certaines circonstances à s'allier avec
des hérétiques pour obtenir des réformes
du royaume
l'appel de monsieur s'ils n'y en ait 15
176 accorde aux protestants huit places
de sûreté ainsi que la liberté de culte
dans tout le royaume
excepté à paris cette paix mécontente
les catholiques qui se rassemblent pour
former un parti politique puissant
appelé la ligue et dont le duc henri de
guise devient le chef tout puissant
henri iii quel est le rôle qu'il va
jouer le rôle que catherine de médicis
justement attend de lui c'est à dire ce
rôle de bascule et il va essayer
d'échapper à l'emprise excessive
déguisent
quand l'église sont trop puissants va
évidemment il incline du côté de
l'église il proscrit les protestants les
prive de toute dignité fait semblant de
la faire la guerre favorise un peu des
combats et puis quand il trouve que ça
va trop loin ou dès qu'il peut en tout
cas échapper à la tutelle déguisent
il s'en va de l'autre côté il va vers
son beau frère henri de navarre
françois d'alençon frère du roi dernier
fils de catherine de médicis et héritier
présomptif du trône meurtre en juin 15
184 évidemment c'est une grande perte
pour le camp de catherine de médicis et
y compris pour henri iii même si de
temps en temps françois a pris partie en
tout cas en apparence contre eux henri
iii mais c'est très souvent un jeu qui
est convenu entre les deux frères c'est
à dire henri iii officiellement ne peut
pas faire autrement que de prendre un
certain nombre de mesures dictées par
l'église et françois dans la mesure où
il n'est pas à paris où il bat la
campagne il a une armée avec lui il est
beaucoup plus indépendant la puissance
de la ligue ne cesse de grandir
mettant à mal l'autorité royale les
ultra-catholiques soupçonne henri iii de
vouloir désigner son cousin le
protestant henri de navarre comme son
héritier légitime en mai 15 188
l'attention et l'animosité envers le roi
atteignent des sommets lors de la
journée des barricades
le peuple de paris menée par le duc de
guise se soulève contre henri iii c'est
parce que l'église lui m'aide si je peux
dire dans les pieds la journée des
barricades en 1588 j'aurai des
barricades qui l'humilie profondément et
l'amène des lendemains de sa
capitulation à fuir paris qu'il décide
de convoquer des états généraux à blois
en donnant toutes les garanties
possibles et imaginables sûreté au duc
de guise et puis les faire assassiner
non ça c'est la vengeance de
l'humiliation
les conséquences pourraient être
dramatiques
tous ceux qui ont pu croire que le roi
et la ligue s'entendait durablement vont
immédiatement nombreux parmi eux vont se
tourner contre le roi henri iii a beau
dire mais le programme de lalique je
continue à le faire
j'ai éliminé le duo quelqu'un derrière
l'église parce qu'ils étaient une menace
contre mon pouvoir pas du tout pour des
raisons religieuses
il a beau affirmer cela ce n'est pas
demi est très très vite dès le mois de
juin deux mois de janvier 489 toute une
série de groupes de communauté
d'individus de prince vont rompre leur
allégeance envers le roi ça va aller
très très loin la faculté de théologie
de l'université paris la sorbonne va
délier les sujets du roi de france de
leur serment d'allégeance donc est
véritablement une rupture au plus
profond de ce qui lie politiquement et
religieusement les deux sont
indissociables
leprince et ses sujets la nouvelle de la
mort du duc de guise
anéanti catherine de médicis et lui
révèle son échec
son fils adoré vient de briser ce
qu'elle a mis des décennies à construire
la reine mère est malade et trop fatigué
pour se battre encore catherine qui est
à blois et qui est effrayée par la
tournure que prennent les événements
qu'elle a pourtant bien orientées à
l'origine parce que ne s'est jamais
vraiment sur quel pied danser en faveur
des protestants ou d où des catholiques
ultras et bien catherine prend froid
mais elle se dit bon ça va passer je
vais guérir parce que
nostradamus m'a dit que je mourrais près
de saint germain alors il se gardait
bien depuis quelques temps d'être au
louvre pas très loin de saint germain en
laye où d'aller dans le château vieux de
saint germain eh bien oui mais là elle
se sent pas bien elle demande quand même
un prêtre pour pour les sacrements pour
lui en dix ans est jamais mieux vaut
tenir que courir et lui dit ô prête mais
je ne vous connais pas comment vous
appelez-vous la baie de saint germain
madame aylmer immédiatement
[Musique]
henri iii salies ouvertement avec henri
de navarre le premier round 15189 poster
avec l'armée royale au château de
saint-cloud
il prépare une offensive pour reprendre
la capitale ligue 2 un jeune dominicain
du nom de jacques clément est autorisée
à s'approcher du roi afin de lui
remettre des documents importants
lemoine déclare être porteur d'un
message secret ambri 3 se penche alors
vers lui et clément le poignarde à mort
[Musique]
l'héritier du trône de pierre henri de
navarre qui est le premier des princes
de la famille royale et évidemment c'est
le problème pour pas mal de catholiques
est ce qu'un prince protestant peut
devenir roi de france ou qu'une
prophétie des nombreux de vin au service
de catherine de médicis avait pu prédire
ce désastre sous son influence
trois de ses fils ont gouverné la france
mais son pouvoir assurer leur postérité
malgré les efforts de la grande
matriarche pour conserver le pouvoir
après deux cent soixante ans de règne la
dynastie des valois à settat ironie du
sort elle laisse place aux premiers rois
bourbon henri de navarre qui va régner
sous le nom d'henri iv épousera à son
tour une médicis les guerres de religion
se prolongeront après son avènement et
ne prendront fin quand 15 198 avec la
signature du fameux édit de nantes